[Musik]
liebe hörerinnen liebe hörer willkommen
zu einer neuen sonderfolge des bücher
podcasts aus dem freien deutschen
hochstift in frankfurt am main am 9 märz
waren dort christian brückner und tilman
spreckelsen zu gast ihr abend zu rot
fried preußler dem schöpfer so
unvergesslicher kinder und jugendbuch
gestalten wie der kleinen hexe dem
räuber hotzenplotz oder krabat trägt den
titel wie man aus der mühle des magiers
entkommt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren
wie wird man verzaubert wie gerät man in
den bann einer macht gegen die nicht
anzukommen ist die uns lassen bringt die
allerschönsten oder auch die aller
törichten dinge zu tun dinge die weder
für uns noch für unsere mitmenschen
einen sinn ergeben
wird schritt preußlers bücher aufmerksam
durch legt der wird in beinahe jedem auf
die spuren stoßen die magie nun einmal
hinterlässt da werden menschen in vögel
verwandelt und hunden krokodile ein
weißes gespannt wird schwarz
papierblumen fangen an zu duften und aus
einem krug schließt im selben moment
himbeersirup und dann wieder derber
schnaps wenn man glück hat und an einen
freundlichen magier gerät dann erfährt
man wie man vom milchgesicht zum
stärksten man weit und breit wird der
trick ist ganz einfach sieben jahre auf
der ofenbank liegen sonnenblumenkerne
verspeisen und andere die ganze arbeit
tun lassen und wenn man pech hat
dann geht es einem sowie einem anderen
milchgesicht und aus der harmlosen
zauberei aus dem netten spuk wird
plötzlich eine angelegenheit von leben
und tod
es war in der zeit zwischen neujahr und
dem dreikönigstag
krabat ein junge von 14 jahren damals
hatte sich mit zwei anderen wendischen
battle jungen zusammengetan und obgleich
seine aller durchlauf texte gnaden der
kurfürst von sachsen das betten und
vagabundieren in höchste rosellen landen
bei strafe verboten aber
die richter und sonstige namens personen
nahmen das glücklicherweise nicht
übermäßig genau damit
zogen sie als drei könige in der gegend
von hoyerswerda von dorf zu dorf
stroh grenze um die mützen waren die
königs rum und einer von ihnen der
lustige kleine logisch aus mogendorf
machte den mooren könig und schmierte
sich jeden morgen mit ofen russ voll
stolz trug er ihnen den bethlehem stern
voran den krabat an einen stecken
genagelt hat
wenn sie auf einen hof kamen nahmen silo
bosch in die mitte und sangen hosianna
davids und das heißt krabat bewegte nur
stumm die lippen weil er gerade im
stimmbruch war dafür sagen die anderen
halten um so lauter deutlich sich das
wieder aus
viele bauern hatten auf neujahr einen
schwein geschlachtet sie beschenkten die
herren könige aus dem morgenland
reichlich mit wurst und speck
anderswo gab es äpfel nüsse und
backpflaumen
honigbrot manchmal
und schmalz küchlein anis plätzchen und
zimtsterne
das jahr fängt gut an meinte lohre
porsche am abend des dritten tages so
dürfte es bis silvester weitergehen
dann legten die beiden anderen
majestäten gemessen und seufzten von uns
auf
die folgende nacht verbrachten sie in
der schmiede von peters hein auf dem
heuboden
dort geschah
das cover zum ersten mal einen seltsamen
traum hatte
elf haben saßen auf einer stange und
legten ihn an er sah dass ein platz auf
der stange frei war am linken ende
dann hörte er eine stimme
die stimme klang heise sie schien aus
den lüften zu kommen von fernseher und
rief ihn bei seinen namen er traut sie
sich nicht zu antworten
krabat soll es zum zweiten mal und ein
drittes mal krabat dann sollte die
stimme kommen nach schwarzkollm in die
mühle es wird nicht zu deinem schaden
sein
hierauf erhoben sich die rahmen von der
stange und krächzen gehorche der stimme
des meisters gehorchen ihr
davon erwachte krabat
was man nicht alles samt räumt dachte er
wälzte sich auf die andere seite und
schlief wieder ein
anderntags zucker mit seinen gefährten
weiter und wenn im graben ein vielen
lachte er
doch der traum wiederholte sich in der
nacht darauf abermals riefen die stimme
beim namen und abermals kräften die
rahmen gehorche ihr
das gab krabat zu denken
er fragte am anderen morgen den bauern
bei dem sie genächtigt hatten ob er ein
dorf kenne das schwarz köln heiße oder
so ähnlich
der bauer und sahen sich den namen
gehört zu haben
schwarzkollm überlegt er ja doch im
hoyerswerdaer forst an der straße nach
leipe da gibt es ein dorf das so heißt
das nächste mal übernachteten die drei
könige in großpostwitz
auch hier träumte krabat den traum von
den raben und von der stimme die aus den
lüften zu kommen schienen und das
spielte sich alles genau so ab wie beim
ersten und zweiten mal
da beschloss er der stimme zu folgen
im morgengrauen als die gefährten noch
schliefen stahl er sich aus der scheune
am hoftor begegnete er der markt die zum
brunnen ging
grüß mir die beiden drucke ihr auf ich
hat wegmüssen
von dorf zu dorf fragte gramm hat sich
weiter der wind trieb ich im schnee
kerner ins gesicht alle paar schritte
musste stehen bleiben und sich die augen
wischen im hoyerswerdaer forst verlief
er sich brauchte zwei volle stunden bis
er die straße nach leibe wiederfand so
kam es dass er erst gegen abend sein
ziel erreichte
schwarzkollm ein dorf wie die anderen
heide dörfer häuser
scheunen in langer zeile zu beiden
seiten der straße tief eingeschneit
rauchfahnen über den dächern dampfende
misthaufen rinder gebrüll
auf dem ententeich liefen mit lautem
gejohle die kinder schlittschuhe
vergeben zielt krabat ausschau nach
einer mühle ein alter mann der ein
bündel reise ich trug kam die straße
herauf den fragte er
wir haben im dorf keine mühle erhielt er
zur antwort
und in der nachbarschaft
wenn du die meinen
der alte deutete mit dem daumen über die
schulter in
kosel bruch hinten am schwarzen wasser
da gibt es eine aber
unterbrach sich als habe er schon zu
viel gesagt
krabat dankte ihm für die auskunft er
wandte sich in die richtung die ihm der
alte gewiesen hatte nach wenigen
schritten sucht die ihn wer am ärmel als
sich um blickte maß der mann mit dem
reisigbündel
was geht's fragte krabat der
alte trat näher
sagte mit ängstlicher miene ich möchte
dich waren junge meide den kosel bruch
und die mühle am schwarzen wasser ist
nicht geheuer dort
einen augenblick zögerte krabat dann
ließ er den alten stehen und ging seines
weges zum dorf hinaus
es wurde rasch finster er musste acht
geben dass er den part nicht verlor ihn
fröstelte wenn er den kopf warnte sah er
dort von woher kam lichter auf schimmern
hier eines da das
ist nicht klüger war umzukehren
ach was brummte krabat und klappte den
kragen hoch bin ich ein kleiner junge
ansehen kostet nichts
krabat tappt ein stück durch den wald
wie ein blinder im nebel dann stieß auf
eine lichtung
als er sich anschickte unter den bäumen
hervorzutreten riss das gewölk auf der
mond kam zum vorschein alles war
plötzlich in kaltes licht getaucht
jetzt sagt rabatt die mühle
galaxie vor ihm in den schnee geduckt
dunkel bedrohlich ein mächtiges böses
tier das auf beute lauert
niemand zwingt mich dazu dass ich dachte
krabat dann schaltet er sich einen
hasenfuß nahm seine mut zusammen und
trat aus dem walde chancen ins freie
beherzt schritte auf die mühle zu hand
die haustür verschlossen und klopfte er
klopfte einmal er klopfte zwei mal
nichts rührte sich drinnen kein hund
schlug an keine treppe knallte kein
schlüsselbund rasselte
nichts
krabat klopfte ein drittes mal dass in
die knöchel schmerzte
wieder blieb alles stillende mühle
da drückte er probehalber die klinke
nieder die tür ließ sich öffnen sie war
nicht verriegelt er trat in den hausflur
ein
grabesstille im schinken und tiefe
finsternis
hinten jedoch am ende des ganges etwas
wie schwacher lichtschein der schimmer
von einem schimmerlos
wo licht ist werden noch leute sein
sagte sich
die arme vorgestreckt tastete er sich
weiter das licht drang der saß im näher
kommen durch einen spalt in der tür die
den gang an der rückseite abschluss
neugier griff ihn auf zehenspitzen
schlich er sich zu der hitze und späte
hindurch
sein blick fiel in eine schwarze vom
schein einer einzigen kerze erhellte
kammer die kerze war rot sie klebte auf
einem totenschädel der lag auf dem tisch
die die mitte des raumes
einnahmen
hinter dem tisch saß ein massiger dunkel
gekleideter mann sehr bleich im gesicht
wie mit kalk bestrichen ein schwarzes
pflaster bedeckte sein linkes auge
vor ihm auf dem tisch lag ein dickes und
leder ein gebundenes buch das an einer
kette hing darin las er
nun über den kopf und starrte herüber
ganze berg hinter dem türspalt
ausgemacht der blick gegen den jungen
durch mark und bein
das auge begann ihn zu jucken ist
trennte das bild in der kammer
vermischte sich
krabat rieb sich das auge
da merkte er wie sich ihm eine eiskalte
hand auf die schulter legte von hinten
er spürte die kälte durch rock und
händchen durch gleichzeitig hörte er
jemand mit heiserer stimme
aufwendig sagen da bist du ja
aber zuckte zusammen
die stimme kannte er
als er sich um wandte stand er dem mann
gegenüber dem mann mit der augenklappe
pikante auf einmal hierher
durch die tür war jedenfalls nicht
gekommen
der mann hielt den kerzenlicht in der
hand er musterte krabat schweigend dann
schob er das kind vor uns sagte ich bin
hier der meister du kannst bei mir leer
junge werden ich brauche ein
du magst doch
ich mag
hörte krabat sich antworten seine stimme
klang fremd als gehörte sie ihm gar
nicht
und was soll ich dich lehren dass müller
oder auch alles andere wollte der
meister wissen
dass andere auch sagte krabat da hielt
ihm der bilder die linke hand hin schlag
ein
in dem augenblick da sie den handschlag
vollzogen habe ich ein dumpfes rumoren
und tosen im haus erschien aus der tiefe
der erde zu kommen der fußboden
schwankte die wände fing an zu zittern
an balken und pfosten erlebten
rabatt schrie auf wollte weglaufen weg
bloß weg von hier doch der meister
vertrat in den weg
die mühle rief er die hände zum trichter
geformt schon mal sie wieder
was ist das für ein tor
was sind das für hochmusikalische setzte
deren klang kurve die ein glockenton
anhebt sich weitet und ganze ihrem exakt
kalkulierten abschluss findet
wenn man über dem schriftsteller und
reporter spricht der mit ehrungen
überhäuft worden ist dessen sicher eine
gesamtauflage von etwa 50 millionen
erzielt haben der mit werken wie die
kleine hexe der räuber hotzenplotz oder
krabat weltweit präsent ist und zu den
bekanntesten deutschen schriftstellern
überhaupt zählt dann kommt man an dieser
unverwechselbaren sprache nicht vorbei
als otfried preußler starb war in den
nachrufen dann auch viel vom
sprachgefühl des autors die rede hier
steht kein wort zuviel schrieb der
tagesspiegel und rühmte das in dieser
prosa melodie und rhythmus perfekt
aufeinander abgestimmt sein anderen
nachrufe erinnerten an die kristalline
klarheit seiner sprache völlig zu recht
aber wie kam es dazu
wer so fragt muss wahrscheinlich ganz
weit zurückgehen in einer zeit in der
die familie preußler noch im böhmischen
reichenberg lebte die eltern das 1923
geborenen und fred preußler arbeiteten
beide als lehrer besonders der vater
heimatforscher und volkskundler scheint
auf langen spaziergängen in die natur
das bewusstsein des knaben dafür
geschärft zu haben dass jede landschaft
ihre eigene geschichte und ihrer eigenen
sagengestalten hat was diese erfahrung
für das werk preußlers bedeutet kann man
kaum hoch genug veranschlagen
noch wichtiger für den späteren
schriftsteller scheint aber eine andere
person gewesen zu sein von seiner
großmutter dora der mutter seines vaters
erzählt otfried preußler im kurzen test
ein buch das es nicht gegeben hat er
berichtet darin von dem
außergewöhnlichen talent jener
großmutter als geschichtenerzählerin
erwähnt den schatz aus regionalen sagen
über den auch sie frei verfügte und dem
sie jeweils ein neues gesicht zu geben
wusste und fügt schließlich einen
merkwürdigen zu kann
großmutter dora eine bescheidene frau
der es mitunter vor ihrer eigenen
fantasie ein wenig bange geworden sein
mag hätte steif und fest behauptet alles
von ihr zuhälter fände sich wortwörtlich
in einem alten dicken buch das sie in
ihrem besitz habe
anfangs schreibt preußler hätten sein
jüngerer bruder und er dies so
hingenommen später sollen sie hellhörig
geworden war es nicht merkwürdig dass
großmutter sobald wir sie um die
wiederholung einer geschichte warten die
uns vor drei vier wochen besonders
gefallen hatte diese geschichte zwar in
der regel wie damals beginnen ließ dass
sie ihr über maps allen aber entglitt
und einen völlig veränderten verlauf
nahmen die bitte ihre enkel jedenfalls
das alte buch einmal einsehen zu dürfen
kontakt die großmutter lustig und
fantasievoll mal ist es verliehen mal
einfach nicht aufzufinden mal beim
buchbinder
preußler aber erinnert sich dankbar an
die frau von der er gelernt hätte wie
man kindern geschichten erzählt
natürlich erzählt der autor das nicht
absichtslos und wenn man wollte könnte
man von hier aus ein netz über weite
teile seiner schriftstellers ist
entwerfen da ist das spannungsfeld
zwischen mündlichkeit und
schriftlichkeit
zwischen freier zelter und fixierter
geschichte das preußler stark prägt er
pflegte seine sätze auf langen
spaziergängen zu entwickeln in ein
diktiergerät zu sprechen und sie
hinterher abtippen zu lassen um sie
daraufhin abermals zu bearbeiten
da ist das bewusstsein dafür dass man
eine geschichte so oder so erzählen kann
dass man auf dem pfad des erzählens
links oder rechts abbiegen kann und so
mal zum einen mal zum anderen schluss
gelangen oder wenn es das schicksal will
auch zum selben wie preußler in seinem
buch die flucht nach ägypten ganz
wunderbar zeigt und schließlich hat
preußler der viel für den rundfunk
gearbeitet hat immer wieder mit der
adoption eigener geschichten zwischen
den medien zu tun gehabt vom buch zum
hörspiel und umgekehrt und dabei
notgedrungen einiges über die
möglichkeiten und grenzen eines solchen
transfers gelernt
so prägend großmutter doras schule des
app store otfried preußler gewesen sein
mag die ausbildung des angehenden
schriftstellers war damit längst noch
nicht beendet und die stationen die
folgten verlangten dem jungen mann der
gleich nach dem vorgezogenen notabitur
soldat werden musste einiges ab
die kunst des erzählens
als geschichtenerzählerin
repräsentiere ich seit adams und evas
zeiten das älteste medium der
unterhaltung die belehrung
der
nachrichtenübermittlung schlechthin
eine tatsache die mich mit stolz erfüllt
ohne dass er mich überheblich macht er
vielleicht verleiht sie mir eine gewisse
sicherheit der einschätzung männer
selbst zu dem eines handwerks oder sich
lieber mundwerk sagen
die unterscheidung ist gering
das erste praktikum als
geschichtenerzähler habe ich in den
lagern aus großmuß italien absolviert am
östlichen rand europas
dort habe ich am beginn der
gefangenschaft an den endlosen abend in
den nächten der hunger und solchen
winter gegen das heimweh erzählt gegen
verzweiflung und tod damals habe ich
erfahren welche kraft von geschichten
ausgehen kann welche überlebens kalt
das zweite praktikum fand in der schule
statt mein lieber pädagogischer mentor
in rosenheim der rektor kastenhofer
selig hat mir den rat gegeben wenn die
schulkinder ihnen durchgehen bloß nicht
laut werden herr kollege bloß nicht den
wilden mann markieren nimmt einfach die
geige zur hand und spielen ziehen was
vor
ein probater tipp
der leider einen haken hatte ich kann
nicht geigen also versuchte ich es mit
geschichten erzählen und siehe da mit
geschichten erzählen habe ich mir manche
ruhige stunde verschluss bei
klassenstärken von 50 kinder und mehr
gewiss keine kleinigkeit
damals habe ich auch gemerkt dass kinder
meine geschichten mögen
und dass sie geschichten offenbar
brauchen
da bin ich dann endgültig zum
geschichtenerzähler geworden als
geschichtenerzähler bist du zugleich
intendant regisseur und ensemble eines
glorreichen ein mann theaters je nach
bedarf kannst du die stimme leise und
zart machen wollte und und
grobschlächtig du kannst wo erforderlich
betteln oder auch zwitschern blüten wie
eine ganze halle lehre oder auch nun du
kannst schnell oder langsam erzählen
kannst 1000 einlegen setzte abbrechen
sie mit einer handbewegung zum abschluss
bringen das mit den ohren wackeln nach
oben nach unten schielen dich freust
dich schütteln ängstlich die hände
ringend auch kannst du dich je nach
bedarf mit dem publikum unterhalten du
kannst fragen stellen kannst gegen
fragen provozieren kannst du auch gleich
beantworten lassen
die ist alles kannst du als
schriftsteller leider nicht mehr
überhaupt bist du als schriftsteller im
vergleich zum geschichtenerzählen arm
und der erzähler hat sein publikum
leibhaftig vor augen sieht hört und
spürt wie das auditorium reagiert er
merkt auf der stelle wo zu ausführlich
oder zu knapp wird ob sich langeweile
ausbreitet ob es über die köpfe der
zuhörer hinweg erzählt ist oder nicht
und wenn sich der kleine franzose das
kleine resl an einer bestimmten stelle
fürchten
so kann er dies abfangen durch eine
straße die bemerkung durch ein
freundlicher dort an der rechten stelle
sobald du aber geschichten auf schreibst
bist du mit dir allein mit dir und einem
bleistift der schreibmaschine dem
elektronischen text system
du befindest dich in der bedauernswerten
lage eines menschen der an seinen stuhl
gekettet ist dann händen und füßen
gefesselt eine schwarze haube über den
kopf gestülpt ein knebel im mund blind
und zu keiner bewegung fähig zu allem
überfluss auch noch taub stumm und nun
erzählen mal schön
nichts mehr steht dir jetzt zur
verfügung von den großartigen
möglichkeiten dass ein mann theater
was dir zur verfügung steht sind 26
stunde buchstaben zuzüglich einiger
umlaute zuzüglich einiger satzzeichen
mehr auch nicht
erst allmählich und unter mühsam habe
ich gelernt lebendig erzählte
geschichten in geschriebenes umzusetzen
bissig dahinter gekommen bin wie sich
auch diese schwierige aufgabe meistern
ist
mit geduld nämlich
und mit sehr viel wie soll es nennen mit
sehr viel kritischer hingabe an den text
jeder satz jedes wort jede silbe muss
wohl bedacht sein alles was dir beim
unmittelbaren erzählen zur verfügung
gestanden hat nun musst du versuchen es
in den geschriebenen text hineinzulegen
hineinlegen ist nicht das richtige wort
auf die gefahr hin dass man mich
missversteht ich versuche dies alles in
meine texte
hinein zu zaubern
ist im spiel
es kommt auf die richtige formel an
du musst deine wortwahl du musst die
länge der einzelnen sätze richtig
dosieren nicht zu viel nicht zu wenig
das ist des pudels kern
und du musst
jedem wirklichen zauberer gleich ein
gewaltiges quantum an kraft die texte
verschwinden an eigener lebenskraft erst
dann darfst du darauf hoffen der leser
werte dazu imstande sein deine vorne in
eigene bilder umzusetzen kraft seiner
fantasie dank der eigenen schöpferkraft
die du immer leicht
in geschichten erleben kinder in der
erste begegnung mit dem reich und dem
reichtum der literatur
sie machen die grundlegende für ihr
weiteres leben möglicherweise prägende
erfahrung was es bedeutet sich von einer
geschichte verzaubern zu lassen
an ihrem beispiel
mit ihrer hilfe einen blick in die
innersten zusammenhänge die verborgenen
triebkräfte ihre und unserer welt zu tun
drei grundregeln musste erzähler
beachten der sie und kinder wendet zum
ersten muss er ihnen was zu erzählen
haben zum anderen muss er sein
literarisches handwerk bis in den
kleinen finger beherrschen zum dritten
jedoch und hauptsächlich muss er sein
publikum kennen ehren und liebhaben dies
falle menschen kinder durchlaufen im
zuge ihrer entwicklung die magische
phase
sie sprechen mit steigen und wurzeln ein
kochlöffel wird zur puppe ein
tannenzapfen zum krokodil
mehr noch sie verwandeln sich je nach
bedarf in raben und störche sie werden
zu riesen zu zwergen zu guten und bösen
hexen einfach so weil sie zaubern können
noch können sie das
je weiter der mensch in die jahre kommt
desto gründlicher gehen ihnen diese
magischen kräfte verloren
ausnahmen von der regel gibt es
natürlich selten zwar aber es gibt sie
sollte sie nicht zuletzt unter
schauspielern geben
die magische phase beginnt im
kindergartenalter sie hält bis zum ende
der grundschule an
während dieser zeit spielen die kleinen
hexen und magier gern theater sei es mit
puppen sei es im rollenspiel selten habe
ich so
faszinierende aufführungen gesehen
die jungen damen und herren meistern
jede nur denkbare rolle sie zaubert sie
in die rolle hinein
das ist alles kulissen benötigen sind
nicht requisiten wenn nur angedeutet
indem sie damit hantieren werden hasel
stecken zu schwertern beiden körbe zu
coachen
manchmal spielt eine sechsjährige
prinzessin an einem spinnrad das gar
nicht vorhanden ist die zuschauer sehen
es trotzdem sie hören es schnüren
auch für das kindertheater sind kinder
im magischen alter ein unvergleichliches
publikum stets mit freuden bereit sich
verzaubern zu lassen wovon
von einfachen stücken in denen es was
zum lachen gibt manchmal auch was zum
fürchten von stücken in einfacher
sprache die sie verstehen das bedeutet
nicht dass die dialoge kunst los sein
müssen im gegenteil
dies gilt ebenso für das bühnenbild die
einfache desto besser
kraft zu einer fantasie kann das
publikum sie sich selber ausstaffieren
die maschinerie des theaters der großen
häuser ist schön und gutes bedarf ihrer
nicht
wenngleich es hin und wieder gelingt sie
auch für kinder einzusetzen
ein wort zu den darstellern wer vor
kindern spielt sollte die fähigkeit
haben wieder zum kind zu werden er
sollte auch seine magischen kräfte
vertrauen auf die magie des wortes auf
die magie von mimik und gestik dann sind
die kostüme eher nebensache und
dies die conditio sine qua non
er muss ein handwerk beherrschen
theater für kinder ist keine nebensache
ist nicht der linken hand zu machen auch
für den regisseur nicht
im übrigen habe ich oft beobachtet dass
es gerade die großen schauspieler sind
die meister ihres berufes die gern mal
vor kindern spielen mit dem freibrief
zur improvisation zum spiel über die
rampe hinweg
wo sonst haben sie heutzutage noch die
möglichkeit dazu
und noch was ein letztes kinder wünschen
gefälligst auch im theater ernst und für
voll genommen zu werden selbst dort wo
es spaß sich ja albern zugeht sie
durchschauen mit unbestechlichen blick
jede art von billigem auch von
raffiniertem schwindel
hingegen sind sie stets dazu bereit sich
verzaubern zu lassen
sozusagen von gleich zu gleich
ich halte den test den wir gerade gehört
haben für einen der wichtigsten unter
den vielen mit denen preußler sein
selbstverständnis als schriftsteller
dargelegt hat einmal weil er präzise
beschreibt wie die interaktion zwischen
erzähler und zuhörer das heißt hier
zwischen lehrer und schulklassen einen
test prägen kann noch in den einzelnen
kapiteln etwa des räuber hotzenplotz
meint man den spannungsbogen zu spüren
den ein jeweils fortgesetzte geschichte
zum schulstunden ende eben verlangt bis
die pausenglocke läutet
preußlers dialoge sind in ihrer
sparsamen verdichtung meisterlich seine
erzählstimme schlägt sofort in den bann
und manchmal wünscht man sich einer der
schulklassen angehört zu haben die er
bis 1970 unterrichtet hat um der
erfahrung willen dem allmählichen
entstehen solcher texte aus der
situation heraus beigewohnt zu haben das
ist übrigens diese struktur von den
eltern die das buch über mehrere abende
als gute nacht geschichte vorlesen
dankbar angenommen wird liegt auf der
hand
zweitens aber dieser test so wichtig
weil er als flammendes plädoyer dafür
kinder ernst zu nehmen noch längst nicht
überholt ist leider
erscheint sogar dass er heute eine ganze
neue aktualität gewonnen hat preußler
jedenfalls trat immer wieder in jedem
einzelnen text und mit seiner ganzen
person mit seinem weltweiten erfolg und
mit der staunenswerten perfektion seiner
prosa dafür ein im kind ein publikum zu
entdecken das nicht überrumpelt sondern
gewonnen werden will
für das man nicht die ansprüche
irgendwie herunterbricht fremdworte
vermeidet und dergleichen mehr sondern
dass man in seiner besonderen fall
weltsicht ernst nehmen dass man
verstehen muss bevor man auch nur einen
einzigen satz nieder schreibt
dass man mit modischen torheiten bitte
verschonen möge solange man ihm anderes
zu geben hat und dass man sehr schnell
langweilt wenn man es nicht zum blick
über den eigenen horizont herausfordert
wäre es übrigens für eine bare
selbstverständlichkeit hält der sollte
einmal einen blick in die
kinderabteilung unserer buchhandlung
werfen
preußler der 1949 aus russischer
kriegsgefangenschaft entlassen worden
war und während der ausbildung zum
volksschullehrer als reporter für
mehrere lokalzeitungen arbeitete schrieb
eine reihe von theaterstücken für
laienspielgruppen und arbeitete außerdem
für den rundfunk der
literarische durchbruch gelang ihm
schließlich mit seinem ersten buch im
thienemann verlag dem kleinen wassermann
brüssel hat immer betont wie sehr sich
gerade dieser roman dem betteln seines
jungen publikums um fortsetzungen
verdankt der ältesten tochter so gut wie
der schulklasse
gleichzeitig und das ist als vor
ausbeutung auf seinen prius werk eben
genauso wichtig verdammt sich das buch
den erzählungen von preußlers vater über
die sagenwelt der böhmischen heimat
der autor aber fand der entscheidenden
zugang indem er das was ihm vor langer
zeit erzählt worden war und das was nun
von ihm verlangt wurde in eines
zusammenführte die motive aus dem
böhmerwald
wanderten in die umgebung der preußlers
nach rosenheim und was den alltag der
jungen lehrer familie prägte tauchte in
der geschichte der wassermann super
wieder auf eigentlich muss man sagen
tauchte ab nämlich auf dem grund des
feuers
[Musik]
was meinst du sagte da war schon man
abends zu seiner frau es gehört sich
wohl dass wir in dem kleinen jungen zu
ehren ein fest geben nicht ich werde
gleich morgen die ganze verwandtschaft
dazu einladen damit wir in allen zeigen
können und du wirst kochen und braten
das wäre etwas zum schnabulieren haben
es ist ja bei uns nicht selber am leuten
gut
der wassermann ging also am nächsten tag
seine verwandten einen laden und denen
die weiter weg wohnen
schickte er fische als boten die
wassermann frau blieb zu hause und
kochte und briet bis zum späten abend
führte sie in den töpfen schwenkte die
bratpfanne und klapperte mit den
schlüsseln zwischendurch gab sie dem
kleinen wassermann seinen
327 verwandte hatte der wassermann
eingeladen und 26 von ihnen kamen es
waren zwölf wassermänner mit ihren
frauen
eindringen man unterschritten weiblein
von der st nepomukbrücke
der brunnen man wohnt im römerbrunnen
hinter dem spritzenhaus rasch und sehr
alt und trug einen weißen bart
die anderen wasser männer und ihre
frauen kann aus dem dorfteich aus dem
frosch tempel aus der enten pfütze aus
dem roten und aus dem schwarzen fläche
aus dem forellen wasser dem steinbach
und noch fünf andere brechen
seit uns gegrüßt
sagte der vater des kleinen wassermann
es ist recht dass ihr euch alle so
pünktlich ein gefunden habt meine frau
und ich sagen allerseits besten dank und
wir hoffen auch dass es euch schmecken
wird
willst du uns nicht zuerst einen kleinen
jungen zeigen fragte der wassermann aus
dem steinbach den vater des kleinen
wassermann
ein
sprach der wassermann vater zuerst
einmal wollen wir tafeln die hauptsache
bleibt für zuletzt
mussten sich die zwölf wassermänner mit
ihren frauen der brunnemann und das
brücken weil bleiben alle an den langen
tisch sitzen den der mühen war
wassermann vor seinem haus für sie
aufgestellt hatte denn in der wohnstube
wäre es viel zu eng gewesen für diese
große gesellschaft der brunnen mann mit
dem weißen bart bekam den ehren platz in
der mitte
die mutter des kleinen wassermann
brachte den gästen zuerst eine suppe aus
wasserlinsen dann ein gericht von
gebratenen fisch eiern mit gerösteten
algen danach zischte sie einen salat auf
den sie aus eingelegter brunnenkresse
und klein gehackten dotter blumen
stängeln bereitet hatte
und wer dann noch immer nicht sagt war
für den gab es zum schluss noch eine
ganze schüssel gedünsteten froschlaich
mit einem gesalzenen wasserflöhe
naja es war eben nicht wie bei armen
leuten
du sag einmal fragte der wassermann aus
dem roten flüsse beim nachtisch den
wassermann aus dem mühlenweiher hast du
denn dein schwager den mann nicht
eingeladen der hätte doch auch mit dazu
gehört oder nicht doch
nur steckst du denn sagte der wassermann
vater ich werde doch nicht meinen
schwager den mohrmann vergessen ich habe
ihm meine schnellste forelle als botin
hinauf geschickt war es der recht
weshalb man nicht kommt
er wird sich wohl meinte der brunnen man
auf der weiten reise ein bisschen
verspätet haben wie ich ihn kenne kommt
da bestimmt das kann dir gar nicht antun
aber wie steht es denn willst du uns nun
den kleinen wassermann zeigen
wenn ihr schon so seit sagte der
wassermann vater dann hole ich ihn aber
gerade als ins haus gehen wollte und
einem kleinen jungen zu holen was war
das da wurde es plötzlich so finster im
mühlenweiher dass man nicht einmal mehr
die eigene hand vor den augen sah
und die wassermann frauen riefen
erschrocken zu hilfe was ist das denn
auch nicht ob da jemand mit tiefer
stimme zur antwort das bin doch nur ich
guten tag und
wen sagen sie als sich die dunkelheit
wieder verlaufen hatte den murrmann der
hatte als er gekommen war einen
tüchtigen schwab café braunen
meerwassers vor sich her geschwemmt das
war alles
willkommen bei uns lief der wassermann
vater wir dachten schon dass du
ausbleiben würde ich wollte gerade ins
haus gehen und unseren kleinen jungen
herausholen
ohne ihn sagte der mann inzwischen werde
ich rasch eine kleinigkeit essen
erlangte mit seinen braunen händen auch
gleich in die nächste schüssel es war
die mit doppelter blumen strenge und
brunnenkresse sein und 123 basilea
dann fertigt er anderthalb teller
gedünsteten froschlaich mit einem
gesalzenen wasserflöhen und tat sich
danach an dem rest vom gebratenen fisch
eiern gütlich
man muss sich daran halten sagte
schmatzend das reisen macht appetit
und saß
bis der wassermann vater wieder aus dem
hause kam und das binden körbchen mit
dem kleinen jungen getragen brachte
da ließ der mann teller und schüsseln
stehen sprang auf und
rief so begeistert dass er sich beinahe
verschluckt hätte
donnerwetter ist das ein junger
und alle wassermänner mit ihren frauen
der brunnen man das brücken weiblein von
der st nepomukbrücke
drängten sich auch um das binden
körbchen und riefen das gleiche
aber nach einer weile hoch dann der
brunnen mann mit dem weißen bart seine
hand und sagte hört auf mit dem
durcheinander gerufen jetzt wollen wir
unserem kleinen wassermann glückwünschen
recht so stimmten die anderen zu
und nun wünschten sie schön nach der
reihe dem kleinen wassermann glück und
gesundheit und langes leben und alles
was man als kleiner was man brauchen
kann
der mann aber griffs insgeheim in die
tasche und zog seine flöte hervor und
zuletzt als die reihe an ihm wasser sagt
der junge ein fröhliches herz zu haben
dann spitzte er flugs die lippen und
setzte die flöten
wie der mann dem kleinen wassermann
aufspielte lustig war das zu hören
lustig zu sehen
aus jedem flöten loch das er aufdeckte
stieg nämlich immer zugleich mit den
tönen ein dünner bräunlicher
wasserschaden empor
und weil sich der mann beim spielen
verneigte und wiegte und
drehten die fäden wie eine schnitte der
flöte nahrung das schien dass sie
tanzten
dann haben sich die 13 wassermänner an
den fäden ein beispiel und tanzten mit
ihren wassermann frauen gleich mit und
der brunnen mann mit dem weißen bart und
das brücken weiblein von der sand
nepomukbrücke fassten sich ebenfalls bei
den halten und drehten sich auch mit im
kreise
doch plötzlich blieben sie alle stehen
wie angewurzelt
und staunten
sie stammten den kleinen wassermann an
er war aus dem pinsel hab ich ihn heraus
gekrabbelt und schwamm nun mit armen und
beinen rudolf wohlgemuth um den mann
herum
ist das möglich fragte der wassermann
vater verwundert der händen was schwimmt
schon
schießt es ja sagte der brunnen man
leise und strich sich den weißen bart
mehr wusste er auch nicht zu sagen
es ist kaum zu übersehen preußler
bedient sich vorgefundene gestalten und
geschichten schmückt und spinnt sie aus
nach herzenslust aber er belässt es
niemals dabei immer ist da eine zweite
ebene die oft geradezu subversiv in den
test einbezogen wird und die dann nicht
mehr nur von rübezahl vom einhorn von
den schildbürgern oder eben vom
wassermann erzählt sondern von uns und
bot man nur eine besetzung nach macht
man oft überraschende entdeckungen ein
beispiel ist etwa der räuber hobbes und
blogs erzählt auf der grundlage und mit
den figuren des ehrwürdigen
kaspertheater
das ist einer von preußlers ganz großen
erfolgen und wer irgendwo auf der welt
in buchhandlungen auf übersetzte
deutsche kinderbücher stößt hat es oft
genug mit dem räuber hotzenplotz zu tun
kleine i know it kinder so stellt man
sich vorlesen vom großen grünen wald von
fahrrädern die man mit einem bindfaden
am laternenfest macht zum spritzenhaus
in dem das feuerwehrauto steht und von
der netten großmutter mit ihrer
kaffeemühle
in den aufgeregten 60 77 jahren ist
preußler für all das sehr gescholten
worden für als eskapismus und tülay und
heile welt und dergleichen mehr wo doch
das leben für junge menschen so ganz
anders sein natürlich hat ihn der
vorwurf getroffen vielleicht aber hat er
sich auch bisweilen sehr darüber
amüsiert und insgeheim ein wenn hier nur
lesen könnte grinsen aufgesetzt
dann ist es sehr leicht die raue luft
der großstadt im ländlichen hotzenplotz
zu vermissen und in all der empörung es
offensichtlich jetzt übersehen damit
verhält es sich wie in der berühmten
aktuelle vater allan poe der entwendete
brief liegt offen auf dem tisch
denn die friedliche welt die uns bei
preußler mit großer
selbstverständlichkeit
großzügig ausgeleuchtet präsentiert wird
hat ihre obskuren winkel in denen sich
gut und böse vermengen und die umso
verwirrender sind je weiter man nach
bohrt und praktisch alle rätsel haben
mit der scheinbar harmlosesten figur von
alex zu tun mit caspers großmutter
in allen drei hotzenplotz bänden bekommt
sie im jeweils ersten kapitel besuch der
räuber betrat ihren garten oder ihre
küche und am ende der begegnung fällt
die großmutter in ohnmacht zum beispiel
in neues vom räuber hotzenplotz wo sie
wie jeden donnerstag bratwürste mit
sauerkraut für ihren enkel kaspar
gemacht hat und nun zusehen muss wie der
räuber an ihrem küchentisch sitzt sind
anders verputzt
das ist eine so großartige szene dass
man sich gar nicht fragt was für ein
ritual da eigentlich gestört wird denn
die großmutter kocht regelmäßig für
ihren enkel taste der ebenso regelmäßig
von seinem freund seppel wird leitet
wird die beiden dazugehörigen
elternpaare werden geradezu auffällig
ausgespart und ebenso bleibt völlig im
dunkeln was die beiden eigentlich zu
treiben wenn sie nicht bei kastels
großmutter sind gehen sie gelegentlich
zur schule wo schlafen sie wovon werden
sie ernährt von großmutters witwenrente
und warum kommt sie derart großzügig für
ein völlig fremdes teams apple auf
vollends rätselhaft wird die sache wenn
man die rolle des peniblen wachtmeister
dimpfelmoser
betrachtet das will scheint einzigen
polizisten jenes städtchens in dem die
großmutter wohnt und das vom räuber
hotzenplotz heimgesucht wird dem schnell
moser ist ein sozialer aufsteiger der
seine karriere vorwiegend auf dem rücken
von hotzenplotz macht jede verhaftung
trägt ihm eine beförderung ein
nachdem bratwurst diebstahl stellt sich
heraus dass hodgson platz den
wachtmeister mit einem tritt überwältigt
und in seiner uniform beraubt hat im
film moser ist also in unterwäsche als
kasperl und seppel ihn finden
das normalste von der welt wäre nun den
schadhaften dimpfelmoser
diskret nach hause zu schaffen er
bewohnt ein möbliertes zimmer bei einer
gewissen frau pfundes michel
stattdessen wird er wie
selbstverständlich bei castorfs
großmutter einquartiert weil er dort am
besten aufgehoben sei dort verschwindet
erstmal im gästebett und großmutter
heißt es war mit allem einverstanden
warum ist der mangelhaft bekleidete
dimpfelmoser ihr zuzumuten nicht aber
der frau kunz michel die frage führt
direkt ins große räuber hotzenplotz
schlamassel denn so wie sich eine feine
verbindung zwischen großmutter und
dimpfelmoser abzeichnet so ist auch das
interesse des räubers an der älteren
dame unübersehbar
offensichtlich findet er gefallen an
ihrer gegenwart so sehr dass ich nicht
nur zwingt bei seinem mittagessen
zugegen zu sein sondern sie schließlich
sogar entführt
vor allem aber erscheint hat sind hat
fast die gesamte trilogie hindurch als
dimpfelmoser es dunkler zwillinge nicht
nur die jeweiligen karrieren der beiden
sind verknüpft auch die uniform des
wachtmeister das passt dem räuber wie
angegossen und beide geben sich nichts
in ihrem fast identischen berufsethos
dem film moser besitzt nur uniformen
keinen anzug weil er wie er sagt immer
im dienst ist er ist schnell zur hand
mit strafandrohung wenn man ihm nicht
ehrfürchtig genug begegnet und als
allheilmittel um entführte kinder
herbeizuschaffen gilt ihm das amtliche
ausrufen lassen durch den gemeindediener
rätselhaft übrigens wie man derlei lesen
und immer noch glauben kann der autor
preußler preise den start
vielleicht wäre es nicht schlecht einmal
genauer hinzuschauen wie obrigkeiten den
werken preußlers wirklich abgebildet
wird wie autoritäten lächerlich gemacht
werden wie sie stürzen sich nur jemand
findet der den mut dazu hat denken sie
an die kleine hexe denken sie an krabat
die frage führt aber noch weiter
sollte man im gleichen atemzug nicht
auch fragen wie preußler sein und unsere
gegenwart im märchenhaften im längst
abgelegten durchschimmern lässt
sein meisterstück in dieser hinsicht
hat er mit der flucht nach ägypten
abgeliefert untertitel königlich
böhmischer teil der roman erschien 1978
spielt irgendwann unter der herrschaft
des österreichischen kaisers franz
joseph und erzählt gleichzeitig von der
flucht der heiligen familie vor herodes
[Musik]
zunächst aber mit erlaubnis geschätzten
leser
wollen wir die geschichte dort anfangen
lassen wo sie begonnen hat nämlich im
stall von bethlehem und zwar in der
nacht die dem tag gefolgt ist an welchen
die heiligen drei könige aus dem
morgenland weil der krippe sich
eingestellt und dem lieben jesulein ihre
gaben da gebracht haben einer gold einer
weihrauch und einer würden
der tag also ist vorbei und im stall von
bethlehem ist es wieder still gewesen
nach all dem trubel
man hat in der finsternis nur den atem
von ochse und esel gehört und das
schnarchen vom heiligen josef
von zeit zu zeit muss die mutter gottes
ihn mit dem ellbogen
anstoßen weil sie befürchtet dass er
womöglich noch mit der schneiderei ihr
das liebe jesulein aufwecken möchte aber
das jesulein in der krippe hat sich von
ihnen nicht stören lassen das hätten
zwölf heilige josef miteinander nicht
wach geschnarcht und so ist auch die
muttergottes dann endlich eingeschlafen
und weder sehen noch das liebe jesulein
hatten gemerkt wie um mitternacht
jemand zum heiligen josef kommt ihm die
hand auf die schulter legt und in drei
mal bei seinem namen ruft
zuerst hat der heilige josef gedacht er
wird der muttergottes wieder einmal zu
laut geschnarcht haben wie er nun aber
auf die städte an seinem lager der
erzengel gabriel große und leuchten da
ist er nicht schlecht erschrocken der
gute mann rasch erste aufgesprungen vom
stroh und hat einen zipfel von seinem
mantel erwischt denen hält er sich vor
die augen damit ihnen das licht nicht
blendet das himmlische das vom engel
ausgeht
der ochs und esel sind auch ganz
erschrocken gewesen ganz steif sind sie
da gestanden und haben den erzengel
gabriel angekotzt bis eben anzeichen
gegeben hat da ist alle furcht von den
beiden abgefallen
der ochs hat dem kopf gesenkt und sich
langsam abgewendet wie wir ja schon
jetzt gewusst hätte dass man ihnen bei
den dingen die sich in hinkunft begeben
werden nicht brauchen kann er ist in den
hinteren teil des stalls getrottet dort
hat er sich in den schatten gelegt mit
dem blick zur wand und zugleich ist er
wieder eingeschlafen
der esel indessen ist ohne scheu wurde
den erzengel hin getreten von neugier
beschnuppert er ihm den saum des
gewandes und jena lässt sich freundlich
gefallener streichelt ihm mit der linken
die gruppe und klopft ihm den grauen
hals
die rechte hingegen hätte zum himmel
empor direkt was die vorschrift in
solchen fällen abverlangt wenn er mit
einer botschaft nieder kommt zu den
menschen
wie er in dieser nacht auch dem heiligen
josef eine zu übermitteln hat
nämlich
es hat sich vom teufel ist ihm das
eingeblasen
der könige rotes in seiner pechschwarzen
raben seele dazu entschlossen dass man
das liebe jesulein umbringen lassen muss
der mord befehl ergangen die büchsen
sind schon geladen die segel gesetzt
es sollen aus galiläa bereits zwei spar
drohnen dragoner sich auf dem brett
befinden nach bethlehem und jericho sind
die berüchtigten sechs schützen im
anmarsch ein bataillon stark so dass er
unter gar keinen umständen
ihnen in die hände geraten darf das
liebe jesulein sondern man muss es vor
ihnen und dem herodes in sicherheit
bringen und zwar ins ausland mit anderen
worten der heilige josef soll rasch ein
paar sachen zusammenpacken für die
familie nicht zu viel los das
allernötigste einer decke für jeden
binden und wäsche und etwas wegzehrung
und die nächsten tage nicht zu vergessen
natürlich die reisepässe
dann soll er den esel satteln und soll
mit dem lieben jesulein und der
muttergottes die flucht nach ägypten
antreten wie es geschrieben steht
der heilige josef hat vorhin setzen die
hände über dem kopf zusammengeschlagen
bei dieser nachricht und
selbstverständlich muss man das liebe
jesulein vor dem könig herodes und den
soldaten retten sagte
zugleich aber kommen ihm zweifel ob er
den weg nach ägypten denn überhaupt
finden wird und wenn ja so erhebt sich
die frage wie man sich dort
den leuten verständigen soll wo doch
wieder die muttergottes noch eher eine
silbe ägyptisch können
auch ist ja dass liebe jesulein in den
reisepässen noch gar nicht eingetragen
da könnte es möglicherweise an den
diversen grenzen zu komplikationen
kommen befürchtet
nicht etwa dass er sich dem geheiß des
erzengels wieder setzen möchte der
heilige josef das hätte er sich nie
getraut
aber das ist eben eine ungemein
schwierige sache mit dem man ihn da
betraut hat man darf nicht vergessen er
ist bloß ein schlichter zimmermann und
natürlich wird es am guten willen nicht
fehlen lassen aber wer weiß denn ob das
in diesem besonderen fall ausreicht
gewiss hat der erst engel gabriel ihm
geantwortet einfach ist diese aufgabe
für den heiligen josef bestimmt nicht
das hat dass ich gleich gedacht wie man
ihn ausgesandt hat mit dem befehl an ihn
und so hat er sich extra danach
erkundigt ob es vielleicht ihm gestattet
sein möchte dass er
der erzengel gabriel auf der flucht nach
ägypten sichtbar vor ihnen her geht
damit sie den weg nicht verspielen und
er sie notfalls vor dieben räubern und
sonstiger um bild der reise beschützen
kann
er hat aber leider gottes
beim höchsten ton kein gehör gefunden
mit seinem vorschlag sondern es ist ihm
bedeutet worden ein solches geleit sei
im göttlichen rat schluss nicht
vorgesehen wie übrigens in der bibel
auch nicht weshalb es gefälligst zu
unterbleiben habe
das einzige was man nach langem bitten
und flehen ihm schließlich zugestanden
hat ist die erlaubnis zu einem
sagen wir eine kleinen begünstigung von
welcher indessen
außer dem heiligen josef kein mensch
etwas wissen darf selbst die mutter
gottes nicht
nämlich die sache ist nunmehr die dass
sie der erzengel wenn schon nicht offen
vor ihnen hin gehend wenigstens
insgeheim nach ägypten geleiten wird in
der gestalt ihres esels den sie ja
ohnehin mitnehmen auf die flucht und so
wird das nicht weiter auffallen
tja so hat der heilige josef gestaunt
dann wird sich der erzengel gabriel
ihnen zuliebe also in einen esel
verwandeln
nein hat im jänner darauf erwidert
verwandeln wird er sich nicht sonst
hätten sie plötzlich ja einen zweiten
esel im stall das möchte verdacht
erwecken vielmehr wird in den hier
vorhandenen esel eingehen für die zeit
der reise nämlich der esel und erde er
single werden nun miteinander 1 werden
bis auf weiteres und es soll sich der
heilige josef nur immer getrost nach dem
esel richten dann folgt er zugleich dem
geist des engels nach
der heilige josef ist ganz gerührt
gewesen von diesen worten und sehr
erleichtert und weil das ich denken kann
dass er den erzengel sicherlich es
überwindung kostet wenn er vorübergehend
zum esel dazu verspricht er ihm
wenigstens dass er in allen stücken in
gut behandeln wird unterwegs
der erzengel hat ihm für diesen vorsatz
gedankt und da ist überzeugt davon hat
er hinzugefügt dass er es als esel bei
ihm schon wird aushalten können aber das
hatte andere ihm lieber nicht gesagt
denn was möchte es ihnen beiden genutzt
haben wenn er den heiligen josef damit
beschwert hätte nämlich
man hat es an höchster stelle dem
erzengel gabriel zur bedingung gemacht
dass
wenn man ihn in den esel eingehen lässt
so muss er darin verbleiben bis an das
ziel der reise
und falls er aus welchen gründen auch
immer ihn vorher verlassen sollte wird
man es unter welchen umständen ihm
gestatten dass es sich noch einmal
wieder hinein begibt
sondern es wird eben dann die weitere
flucht nach ägypten ohne ihn stattfinden
müssen und damit dass da
dies also wohl bemerkt hat der
himmlische bote zum heiligen josef nicht
gesagt weil er ihm keine unruhe hat
verursachen wollen auch haben sie
ohnehin schon zu lang miteinander
geredet meint er und wenn sie nicht
schleunigst machen dass sie aus
bethlehem wegkommen möchte es sein dass
der könig herodes mit den soldaten ihnen
den weg nach ägypten abschneidet und was
dann
hiermit hat sich der erzengel gabriel
aufgerichtet in seiner ganzen größe und
majestät
da ist es dem heiligen josef wie wenn er
mit bloßen augen die sonne anschaut
und wieder kräfte zu einem zipfel von
seinem mantel und wieder bedeckte er
sich dass gesichter mit
sofa für ein paar augenblicke
und dann wie er probeweise hinter dem
tuch hervor blinzelt zeigt dass sich
dass der engel des herrn verschwunden
ist und
im stall ist es wieder dunkel gewesen
wenn auch nicht ganz so finster wie
sonst bei der nacht
weil es von dem fall fällt des esels
besonders an seiner stelle ein gewisser
schimmer ausgeht als möchte vom licht
des engels ein wenig hindurch scheinen
durch die esels haut
dem heiligen josef bleibt aber nicht
viel zeit zum staunen nämlich der esel
lässt das nicht zu indem er zum aufbruch
drängt und ihn unentwegt mit der nase an
schubst
schon gut meint der heilige josef schon
gut
wobei er die streichhölzer aus der
hosentasche hervorkramt er nimmt die
laterne vom haken die an den pfosten
neben der tür hängt knipst bei der kerze
das obere ende von dort weg und zündet
sie an dann macht er sich ans
zusammenpacken von ihren sachen das
dauert nicht lang denn es ist er nicht
viel vorhanden zum mitnehmen lediglich
die geschenke welche die könige aus dem
morgenland im stall ihnen hinterlassen
haben mit denen weiß er zu anfang sich
keinen rat
es handelt sich schließlich um wertvolle
gegenstände wie man sie eines teils
gerne mit führen möchte weil man sie
notfalls im ausland zu geld machen kann
wenn man welches braucht
aber wenn man sich anderen teils
vorstellt dass sie ja mehrere grenzen
werden passieren müssen und wenn so ein
zollbeamter dann eine königskrone aus
dem gepäck heraus fischt ein goldenes
weihrauchfass und die silberne über und
über mit herren und edelsteinen besetzte
möhren büchse
da wird man sie schön in die zwicken
nehmen dafür ins loch stecken wird man
sie wegen verdachts auf
kirchenraum
oder zumindest auf hehlerei und
wer wird ihnen dann schon glauben das
kindlein da in den windeln aber die
kostbarkeiten alle geschenkt bekommen
nämlich es seien die drei könige aus dem
morgenland extra zu diesem zwecke herbei
gereist
nein muss der heilige josef denken und
wird schon im geiste die zöllner sich
über sie lustig machen und wie man sie
im gefängnis dann anbrüllen wird beim
verhör und wenn es beim anbringen bleibe
so möchte das ja noch hingehen aber es
bleibt nicht dabei und wer weiß was man
alles mit ihnen noch anstellen könnte es
sind die behörden ja diesbezüglich nicht
arm an einfällen
nein denkt der heilige josef das dürfen
sie nicht riskieren dass sie die teuren
geschenke mitnehmen auf die reise aber
wohin damit
wer noch überlegt was er tun soll sieht
er im schein der laterne den esel
welcher in einer ecke des stalles den
boden auf schaden wobei er zu ihm dem
heiligen josef er überblickt und der
heilige josef verst zugleich was gemeint
ist der holt einer hat um den spatzen
und gräbt in der ecke des stalles 1 ins
erdreich
vielleicht eineinhalb meter tief dann
nimmt er die krone das weihrauchfass und
die möhren büchse und legt sie in einen
hölzernen kübel den stopft er mit
strophen dann stellt er ihn in die grube
und scharrt ihn ein
es bleibt mir von der ausgehobenen erde
zwei schaufeln übrig die schafft er
hinaus und schüttelt sie auf den
misthaufen hinter dem stall dann stampft
den boden über der grube fest und
bestreut ihn mit streu damit man nicht
merken soll dass da etwas frei haben ist
denn er hofft er sie werden nach einiger
zeit aus ägypten zurückkehren können da
will er dann alles wiederum aus dem
versteck heraus holen ob es aber
tatsächlich dazu gekommen ist weiß man
nicht denn
die bibel
schweigt sich darüber aus
der clou dieses romans den ich ihnen
sehr empfehlen möchte liegt in einer
ungeheuren gleichzeitigkeit
maria josef und das jesuskind begegnen
auf ihrer reise immer wieder den
zeugnissen eines jahrhunderte lang
praktizierten christentums dabei ist das
ein stifter doch gerade erst auf die
welt gekommen sie passieren
wallfahrtskirchen und kreuze nehmen die
huldigung der heiligen entgegen und
gelangen an einer bestimmten stelle des
romans die preußler meisterlich
verdichtet hat in eine weihnachtlich
eingerichtete stube dort steht eine
riesige krippe und unter dem mechanisch
bewegten krippenfiguren ist auch eine
gruppe in der sich die heilige familie
selbst erkennt und zwar nicht etwa das
bekannte ensemble im stall da ich
natürlich auch sondern eine gruppe von
heimlichen eindringlingen nach böhmen
diese szene aber hat sich aus am vortag
abgespielt wie so findet sich schon
unter den krippenfiguren
müssen wir das hinnehmen
darf preußler dass
schriftsteller haben mit sauberen mehr
gemein als man vermuten würde in beiden
fällen hängt der erfolg davon ab ob wir
ihnen glauben
wenn wir um bei einem der bekanntesten
beispiele im werk preußlers zu bleiben
uns weigern den dackel wastl im krokodil
der wird für schlotter weg zu vermuten
dann ist die seltsame wohngemeinschaft
der beiden kein fall für einen gegen
server sondern für das veterinäramt
artgerechte krokodil haltung sieht
anders aus
und wenn wir dem autor die geschichte
von der flucht aus ägypten in der
zeitlichen distanz von gut
1900 jahren einfach nivelliert wird
nicht abkaufen dann hat der beste
erzähler der beste sauberer sein recht
verloren
uns entgehen er damit aber der
ausständigen wir eben gehört haben liegt
das anklingen
eine weitere ebene denn natürlich ist
das eine geschichte die täglich irgendwo
auf der welt geschieht wo immer menschen
vertrieben werden ihre sachen packen
müssen und in einer fremden umgebung der
willkür der behörden ausgesetzt sind
preußlers familie hat eine solche flucht
selbst erlebt
macht und willkür
preußler so scheint es hatte ein äußerst
schwaches sensorium dafür wenn einer die
gewalt die er über andere hat
missbraucht und auch dafür wie weit man
sich anpassen kann bis es einfach nicht
mehr geht
in seiner kleinen hetzel hat er der
revolte ein denkmal gesetzt und das
funkelnde finale dieses buches gehört
zum prächtigsten was sein dieser
hinsicht verfasst hat da sitzt sie die
ausgestoßene die gedemütigt und
beleidigte und ruiniert mit einem
handstreich mal eben 500 existenzen denn
die kleine hexe wegen ihres moralischen
abweichler teams gerade zu den aller
niedersten handlangerdienste verdonnert
entfacht ein gewaltiges feuer aus dem
besen und zauberbücher der anderen
hetzen jener frauen also um deren
anerkennung sie ein jahr lang vergeblich
gekämpft hatte
das hat sie hinter sich vor sich aber
nichts geringeres als die aussicht auf
weltherrschaft denn weil sie ihren
rivalen gleich alle hexen kunst mit weg
gehetzt hat ist sie nunmehr die einzige
die zugriff auf die alten formeln und
rezepte
wie denn das buch entstanden sei wurde
frau aus lauf gefragt er antwortete gern
mit der geschichte wie er seinen
töchtern dieses vor den bösen hexen
fürchteten leichthin versprochen habe
böse hexen gebe es gar nicht mehr nur
gute
wie das denn gekommen sei wollten die
mädchen wissen die antwort schlägt
funken
lodert und prasselt und tröstet und es
hat mehr als einem halben jahrhundert
denn preußler so kann man sich das
deuten bringt die dinge auch gern mal an
ein ende wo zauberei ins spiel kommt da
darf sie auch wieder raus verschwenden
und kein magier sollte sich in diesem
kosmos allzu stark denken bei der
kleinen hätte so wird aus dieser hybris
ein loderndes feuer der mächtige
zauberer petrosilius zwackelmann hat
gerade deshalb am ende ganz schlechte
karten rösler hat es allerdings später
bedauert dass es so früh von dieser
großartigen figur getrennt hat und in
den beiden räuber hotzenplotz
fortsetzungen nun ohne den zauberer
auskommen musste in zwölf hat es
geschlagen erzählt preußler vom teufels
bündner dr faust und lässt im moment in
dem dieser die unterschrift unter den
pakt leistet schon anklingen dass die
uhr tickt dass die zeit abläuft dass die
tage gezählt sind dass es mit der
geborgten herrlichkeit ein ende haben
wird ähnlich endete es mit dem natur
makler paracelsus im selben band und
auch der hexe baba jaga
nutzt all ihre magische versiertheit
nichts als sie es mit dem starken wanja
zu tun bekommt
[Musik]
drei mal rief anja mit lauter stimme die
baba jaga
beim erstmal rührte sich nichts beim
zweiten mal siegte ein windstoß über das
moor und der himmel verfinstert dass ich
beim dritten mal kam die hexe auf ihrem
ofen heran geprescht und der blitz und
donner krumm nahm sich schief neulich
klapperdürr wie ein totengräber mit
fliegenden röcken und wird um den
schädel flatterndem h
der offensiv auf vierstimmigen nackten
hühnerbeinen mit langen krallen die hexe
hockte darauf wie ein reiter auf seinem
gaul mit deinen hand hielt sie die zügel
die waren im ofenrohr festgestellt in
der anderen schwang sie das fangeisen
bei jedem satz den der ofen machte
klapperten ihr die knochen im leib das
hörte sich an als schüttler man einen
sack nüsse
dicht vor man ja am rand des moores
zügelte sie den ofen
du hast mich gerufen beschreiben was
willst du
ich will mit dir kämpfen erwiderte wanja
tapfer kämpfen macht was ich mit ihr
mache
als zwei warf die baba jaga ihm das
fangeisen um den hals klärend schnappte
es zu mit einem würgegriff wanja
faszinieren die kehle so rief die baba
jaga und nun rasch ins moor mit dir
damit wendete sie den backofen
vorwärts mein herzchen hey
sie versuchte den starken wanja ins moor
zu zerren willst du wohl ziehen du alter
klepper vorwärts
die hexe spornte den ofen mit schrillem
geschrei haben sie die drosch mit dem
freien ende des zyklus wild auf ihn ein
herrje
wanja stützte sich auf die lanze von
eisen holz die kette war zum zerreißen
angespannt
das fangeisen wirkte in halb zu tode
seinen nacken schmerzt sei in einen
schraubstock eingezwängt keuchend rang
nach luft
allerheiligen doch der steht mir bei wie
sollte das ein mensch ertragen
er machte sich schwer ganz schwer und
stemmte sich mit den füßen fest in den
boden ein so hoffte er eine zeitlang
auszuhalten aber wie lange
die hexe kreischt und kämpfte sie schlug
wie nicht recht bei trost auf den ofen
los noch ein rock creek sie noch ein
rookie
man ja spürte dass es mit seinen kräften
zu ende gehen
in seiner verzweiflung zog er wohl ochs
tscherkessen deutsch aus dem gürtel und
schleuderte ihn nach dem backofen
närrischen sport die klinge sich in die
rechte flanke des ofens blut spritzt den
dicken strahl aus der wunde schwarzes
dampfendes blut
der ofen stießen im gellenden schrei aus
und bäumte sich auf
für einen augenblick verlor die baba
jaga die gewalt über ihn diesen
augenblick nutzte wanja zu einem
mächtigen druck der ofen war nicht
gefasst darauf die hühnerbeine knickten
unter ihm weg er verlor den halt
wanja schleifte den backofen samt der
baba jaga an der kette über den rand des
moores hinaus auf das festland
kaum war das geschehen da öffnete sich
das fangeisen ganz von selbst und klärte
zu boden
anja friedrich den hals er trat auf die
hexe zu zog den dolch aus der ofen
flanke die wunde schloss sich
nun wer hat wien besiegt
die barriere stieg vom ofen aschfahlem
gesicht vor wut sie knirschte mit ihren
langen pferde zählen sie fauchte wie
eine böse katze weshalb sie hatte den
kampf gegen vania verloren und basta
als verlangst du fan mehr
wanja steckte den deutschen den gürtel
zurück dann sagte er fest und mit lauter
stimme
den bauern ihre pferde und mir den
ratten waren der schneller ist als der
wilde städten wind das verlange ich
die hexe büchern schritt zurück sie
druckte sich wie zum sprung wanja fasste
die lanze fester aber die alte machte
bloßen kratz fuß
hast du verlangst soll geschehen
krächzte sie lasst uns zu mir nach hause
reiten auf meinem ofen pferdchen ist für
uns beide platz
auf dem backofen retten die bavaria und
der starke wanja über das weite moore
durch graue und weiße nebelschwaden
vorbei an verkuppelten bäumen im heu
über tümpel und kolk weg dass der
schlamm spritzte und der wind ihnen um
die ohren pfiff
bald draußen im ohr
versteckt hinter einem flachen mit
ginster büschen bewachsenen hügel zug
stand die hütte der baba jaga ein
schiefes schnoddriges häuschen mit
blinden fenstern und schimmligen balken
das strohdach an vielen stellen
durchgeführt da wären wir
ein bisschen
links von der hütte begannen anlage fast
mannshoher bretterzaun als wanja darüber
hinweg blickte sah er auf eine
pferdekoppel
dort grasten mit hängenden köpfen die
von der baba jaga auf den dörfern
zusammen gestohlenen bauern pferde
braune und schwarze glatte und struppige
alte und junge
alles war gut im futter sobald sich das
aus der ferne erkennen ließ aber krank
vor heimweh
schick sie in ihre dörfer zurück
gefallen waren ja der baba jaga und wehe
der alte scheusal wenn auch nur eines
von ihnen zu schaden kommt
die hexe monate etwa sind an das rennen
unverständlichen sprache und fuchtelte
mit den händen dann steckte sie zwei
finger in den mund und stieß einen
schrillen pfiff aus wanja fasste sich an
die ohren die alte kicherte um vergebung
falls ich den herren erschreckt habe
im bretter zorn hatte sie auf den tisch
in ein tor geöffnet
die pferde der bauern kamen herbei
getrottet und schauten
lauft gute pferdchen
lauftreff der starke mann ja seht ihr
nicht dass ihr freizeit rasch nach hause
an jedes in seinen stall
nun begriffen die bau- und pferde
freudig stürmten sie auf der koppel an
wanja vorbei mit fliegender mähne und
wehendem schweiz nach allen richtungen
stuben sie über das moor davon ein jedes
zurück in sein heimatdorf und
keine sank auch nur einen finger breit
im morast 1 dafür hatte die hexe mit
ihren zaubersprüchen gesorgt
zufrieden der herren
soweit ja sagte wanja nun aber her mit
dem ratten waren
die hexe doppelte unterwürfig mit
schiefem grinsen führte sie wanja hinter
die hütte zu einem stall darin standen
zwei prächtige pferde ein gold fuchs mit
langer kunstvoll geflochtene und wanja
stockte bei ihrem anblick das herz eine
herrliche schimmelstute
in allen dingen die la las ebenbild
schneeflöckchen ist zu haben sagte die
baba jaga und gold füchslein auch
wanja klopfte der schimmelstute den hals
zutraulich schmiegte sie in den kopf an
die schulter mit leisem zärtlichen
schnauben nun wie gefallen dir meine
beiden ziehe ich ihn einst davon kannst
du mit nem welches das steht bei dir und
trouble warum fragte wann wir auch der
rief die hexe knochen beim
selbstverständlich kannst du ihn auch
bekommen not hinten steht er und frisst
das gnadenbrot
halb versteckt hinter einem grauen aus
alten futter säcken zusammen
gestückelten vorhang stand in der
dunkelsten ecke des stalles ein elender
dürrer klepper mit roten treff augen und
verfilzt termine müde ließ er den kopf
hin wanja sah dass ein schwarzes fell
von der räude befallen war
dies soll warum sein du sagst es
dann ja besah sich den rappen eher was
für ein schäbiges tier
doppelt armselig im vergleich mit dem
fuchs und der schimmelstute waren ja war
drauf und dran sich für schneeflöckchen
zu entscheiden
da fiel ihm die warnung des alten mannes
ein wie zufällig streifte sein blick die
baba jaga und er sah sie grinsen
nun drängte die hexe du hast deine wahl
getroffen oh
ja sagte wanja
der rappe warum war mit einem strick an
der krippe festgebunden wanja löste den
knoten und führte waren ins freie
als sie die stalltür durchschritten
verwandelte sich die dürre räudige sind
müde in ein strahlen des helden groß
der fuchs aber und die schimmelstute
wurden im gleichen augenblick wieder zu
dem was sie in wirklichkeit immer
gewesen waren der gold bugs 1 strobel
und schneeflöckchen eine alte wollenden
acht mütze
der bagger jahre hatte alle hexen kunst
nichts genützt
wilten schwang sie sich auf den backofen
schlugen die zügel uns ruhe und schritt
greifen davon so groß war ihr zorn dass
sie feuer fing lichterloh brennen
stürzte sie sich mit dem ofen in einen
der schwarzen moor tempel
und versank darin
die sind wir los sagt man ja nun
brauchen die bauern sich nicht mehr vor
ihr zu fürchten und das ist gut so
wohlgefällig betrachtete er den ratten
waren dessen fell in der sonne glänzte
wie schwarze seite sattel und zaumzeug
waren mit silber beschlagen die
steigbügel und die schnallen von purem
gold
ich stolz du den kopf hält warum und wie
vor ich du in die runde blickt
das ethos trug den starken wanja über
das moor und über die heide hinaus dort
hieß wanja den ratten laufen so
schneller konnte lauf zu mein wahrung
lauf zu dass stürmte damit waren ja
dahin über stock und stein schneller
noch als der wilde steppen wind die
leute denen sie unterwegs begegneten
soll bloß einen schatten vor überraschen
und spürten den schatten luftzug
was war das fragten sie will es schon
winter werden es scheint dass der sturm
uns die ersten schnee wolken übers land
treibt
am schönsten erzählt preußler vom ende
der schwarzen magie in seinem
meisterwerk im krabat zehn jahre lang
hat er daran geschrieben gefeilt
verworfen wieder neu geschrieben und das
ist die gemüse in einen ungeheuren
ertrag verwandelt hat teilt sich beim
lesen rasch mac nicht zuletzt weil hier
ausgehend vom sagenschatz der lausitz
eine völlig selbstständige geschichte
von verführung macht ohnmacht und
todesangst erzählt wird und zwar quer
durch alle figuren
wer mag kann darin auch die geschichte
einer verführten generation erkennen
jena deren jugend in die zeit des
nationalsozialismus fiel
die langsame annäherung zwischen dem
müllerburschen krabat und dem mädchen
das er nur unter dem namen kantorka
kennt die vorsängerin in der osternacht
gehört in ihrer unbeirrbarkeit zu den
berührendsten utopien der
jugendliteratur
besonders im moment der höchsten gefahr
[Musik]
als krawatte wahlen schweißgebadet
hatte sie einen strohsack verbissener
keuchte es dauert eine weile bis er zur
kammer
dass er den meister im traum überwunden
hatte nahm er als gutes omen
von jetzt an war er sich seiner sache
vollkommen sicher
die tage des meisters
das glaubte nun zu wissen waren gezählt
krabat
wurde dem treiben des müllers ein ende
setzen ihm war es bestimmt seine macht
zu brechen
am abend begaben sich in die meister
stube
es bleibt dabei rief
macht du zu deinen nachfolger wenn du
magst ich krabat weigere mich auf dein
angebot einzugehen
der meister nahmen seine worte gelassen
hingegen den holzschuppen sagte und
vorsichtig mit hacke und spaten im kosel
braucht gibt es ein grab zu schaufeln
das soll dann der letzte arbeit sein
krabat wieder nichts darauf machte kehrt
und verließ die stube
also zum schuppen kam löste sich eine
gestalt aus dem schatten
ich habe auf dich gewartet klammert soll
ich dem mädchen bescheid sein
krabat zog aus der brusttasche seines
kittels den ring von hervor
sage ihr bei der jugend dass ich ihr
botschaft sendet durch dich
und sie möge sich morgen am letzten
abend des jahres bei müller einfinden
und mich frei bitten wie es gesprochen
ist
er beschrieb ihm das haus wo sie wohnte
wenn du ihr fuhr erfolgt den ring zeigst
wird sie daraus ersehen dass du in
meinem auftrag kommst und vergiss nicht
sie wissen zu lassen dass es ihr frei
steht ob sie den gang in den kursen
bruch antreten will wenn sie kommt ist
es gut und wenn nicht das ist auch gut
dann soll es mir gleichgültig sein was
mit mir geschieht
gab european ring und umarmte ihn
du versprichst mir es recht zu machen
und dass du die kantorka nicht überreden
wirst etwas zu tun was sie lieber nicht
hätte
das verspreche ich sagte juror
ein rabe im schnabel den ring von haarde
trat den flug nach schwarz kollmann
grad gingen den schuppen stand da ein
sagen der ecke
schulterte hacke und spaten dann statt
der durch den schnee in den kursen bruch
bis er zum wüsten plan kam
er fand eine stelle die sich als dunkles
geviert von der weißen umgebung abhob
war sie für ihn bestimmt oder war es das
grab des meisters den sie bezeichnete
morgen haben diese zeit doch der krabat
den spaten ansetzen wird das alles
entschieden sein
anderntags mit dem frühstück nahm euro'
den freund beiseite und hab in den ring
zurück er habe das mädchen gesprochen
alles abgemacht
gegen abend
es wollte schon dunkeln 20 cantürk auf
der mühle ein in der abendmahlsfrage mit
dem weißen stirnband hand so empfing sie
und fragte nach ihrem begehr sie
verlangte den müller zu sprechen
der müller bin ich
die burschen beiseiteschieben trat ihr
der meister entgegen in schwarzem mantel
und dreispitz bleich im gesicht wie mit
kalk bestrichen
was willst du
die kantorka blickte ihn furchtlos an
gib mir begehrte sie meinen burschen
heraus
einen burschen der müller lachte das
hörte sich an wie ein böses meckern ein
box gelächter ich kenne ihn nicht
es ist krabat sagte die kantone den ich
liebhabe
krabat
damals da versuchte sie einzuschüchtern
kennst du ihn überhaupt bist du fähig
ihn unter den burschen herauszufinden
ich kenne ihn sagte die kantorka es kann
jeder sagen
der meister wandte sich dem gesellen zu
geht in die schwarze kammer und stellt
euch in einer reihe auf nebeneinander
und rührt euch nicht
erwartet dass sie sich nun in raben
verwandeln müssten er stand zwischen
androsch und sta spur
bleibt wo ihr seid
und das keiner mehr einen mucks macht
auch du nicht krabat beim ersten lauf
den ich von die höhere stirbt sie
damals so rüstet man taschen ein
schwarzes tuch das band er der kantorka
vor die augen
dann führte er sie herein
wenn du mir deinen burschen zeigen
kannst du darfst du ich mitnehmen
krabbe das mag damit hat er nicht
gerechnet wie sollte nun mädchen helfen
dann nutzte ihm auch der ring von nichts
die kantone schritt die reihe der
burschen ab einmal und zweimal grad
vermochte sich kaum auf den beinen zu
halten sein leben das spürt er war
verbilligt und
das leben der kantorka
angst übermannt ihn angst wie sie nie
zuvor gespürt hatte ich bin schuld dass
sie sterben muss ging es ihm durch den
kopf ich bin schuld daran
da beschloss
die kantorka
dreimal war sie die reihe der burschen
entlang geschritten streckte die hand
aus und zeigt darauf covert er
ist es sagte sie
bist du sicher
ja
damit war das entschieden
sie knüpfte das tuch von den augen dann
trat sie auf grappa zu
du bist frei
der meister taumelte gegen die man
zurück die burschen standen an ihren
plätzen zu eis erstarrt
holt eure sachen vom boden und geht nach
schwarzkollm sagt ihr
könnt in der schuld sei auf dem heuboden
übernachten
da schlichen die knappen aus der kamera
der meister sie wussten es alle
wurde den neujahrs tag nicht erleben um
mitternacht musste sterben dann wurde
die mühle in flammen aufgehen
werden mit so einem schiefen hals
drückte krabat die hand
nun sind michael und sondergericht und
die anderen auch
krabat war außerstande ein wort zu sagen
er war wie versteinert
da legte die kantorka ihm den arm um die
schulter und holte ihn in dir wollen es
um tuch ein warm weich und warm wie ein
schutzmantel
gehen wir krawatte
er ließ sich von ihr aus der mühle
führen sie führte ihn durch den
kurseinbruch nach schwarzkollm hinüber
wie hast du mich fragte er
als sie die lichter des dorfes zwischen
den stämmen aufblinken sahen hier eines
da
14 hast du mich unter den mit gesellen
herausgefunden
ich habe gespürt dass du angst hattest
sagte sie
angst um mich
daran habe ich dich erkannt
während sie auf die häuser zu schritten
fing es zu schneien an
leicht und in feinen flocken wie mehl
das aus einem großen sieg auf sie nieder
viel
wie soll man sich das deuten ist im
moment in dem der bann gebrochen wird
der über den müller gesellen liegt in
dem die schwarze magie ihre macht
verliert weil ein stärkerer server auf
den plan tritt
gegen große vorzüge eines anderen
menschen gibt es kein rettungsmittel als
die liebe heißt es in den
wahlverwandtschaften
dass es aber umgekehrt auch gegen die
liebe kein rettungsmittel gibt seit
krabat in vollendeter form die mühle
geht in flammen auf hinter dem erlösten
müllerburschen und hinter der kantor
schließt sich ein vorhang aus schnee ein
perfektes ende
ich danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]